My original Rick killed your family and you were
just waiting for him to come back seems like you
understand fine Morty that was a plus re-piping
we're here welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this will be my full Rick and Morty season six
episode one video there were a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel I will be
doing videos for all the episodes this season
just like I did for previous Seasons be sure
to subscribe to get them all careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll
start at the beginning and work our way through
shot by shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF
moments as we go along starting with the episode
titled solar Ricks it's a reference to the sci-fi
movie Solaris in that movie the main characters
trapped on a space station haunted by his dead
wife a reference to Rick creating the AI using
his dead wife's voice side note the same actress
who was doing the voice of his dead wife was also
the voice of the garage AI which he probably did
just a low-grade harass himself the way that he
explains during this episode like I created you
to me just in general the whole episode is about
moving on which is like a big theme of the series
like they're moving on from Evil Morty he was
this big running storyline through the first five
seasons they want to do sort of like a soft reset
soft reboot refresh the series because they think
it could go forever like literally the showrunner
Dan Harmon were talking about how the show could
theoretically as long as people keep watching just
go on forever like they could just keep coming up
with ideas like this but when shows go on long
enough eventually you do have to kind of change
the formula so that's kind of what they did in
this episode like Rick literally tries to change
the formula of the portal fluid so that it will
work again re-tune things it's a metaphor for what
the writers are doing with the show in real life
the other big thing is setting up like the next
major antagonist which they're calling Prime rig
they're not giving him like a number designation
because his original Earth is Cronenberg Earth
so I guess if you really wanted to you could
call him Cronenberg Rick but he's like the real
Cronenberg Rick for the purposes of this video
for like all my future videos I'll probably just
call him Prime rake though revealing the rest of
the backstory behind what happened with his family
how his wife and his version of Beth died saying
that Morty's real grandfather is prime Rick
and that's the reason during season one Beth is
complaining about him disappearing for 20 years
and then just showing up one day because Prime
just abandoned the family 20 plus years ago we
got most of Rick's backstory during the season
5 finale just explaining how his family died what
he did after that how he eventually created The
Citadel of Rick's then after moved to Cronenberg
world and inhabited it waiting for Prime Rick to
potentially return so that he could kill him there
are a couple big moments during the episode where
major characters move on metaphorically or talk
about how they moved on like c-137 Rick eventually
has to move on from trying to get revenge on Prime
rig when it goes back to his family in the Citadel
to try and save them the family that we now know
he adopted not his original family Cronenberg
Jerry also reveals that he's become the perfect
version of himself without his family after he
moved on with a little bit of help from Batman
on the side like he keeps quoting Batman like
The Dark Knight Returns gave him all these life
lessons and summer kind of has the same moment
with both versions of Beth they also finally
confirm which version is the real Bev space Beth
is confirmed as the real one in the Clone Beth
is the one that stayed at home which confirms
my theory I always felt like space Beth was meant
to be the real best just the way they set things
up during that particular episode during the
episode they had a lot of references to previous
Seasons because they gone on for so long the show
references itself a lot of times wish Rick also
calls out like a lot of the jokes Rick and other
characters directly call out like why did you do
that bit and just in general going forward Justin
Roiland said that season 6 episodes in general
will mostly be Canon episodes as opposed to the
one-off episodes that they've done in previous
Seasons but they revealed the episode starts a
short time Jump after the end of season 5 finale
after evil Morty escaped through his modified
portal escaping the central finite curve in Rick
and Morty escaped in part of the Citadel that
was destroyed and after evil Morty escaped they
just slowly ran out of food and water in all
the portal fluid was rendered inert the tear
in the background is the Terran space time the
evil Morty opened when he was trying to exit the
central finite curve is sort of like the manual
way to go between realities that Rick uses later
in the episode and they'll continue having to use
until he fixes the portal fluid which he kind of
implies that he will do eventually like the whole
plot of the episode hinges on him making a mistake
like oh no we're all being reset to our original
realities but the way he talks about it he makes
it sound like he'll eventually fix that and they
will eventually get portals back I don't know how
many episodes It's Gonna Take like maybe by next
week's episode or maybe a couple episodes after
that we'll see Rick calls out his cheesy opening
voice over Trope the writers of the show are also
making fun of themselves for being bad writers
the whole thing with the Pharaoh mortys eating
each other problem solving themselves is the idea
that because the show has moved past the Citadel
is like a big narrative Trope they just had to
find a way to get rid of all the mortys and all
the Ricks that were living there so they basically
just kill them off in hilarious ways he makes an
Iron Man Avengers end game Marvel reference to the
diary he kept recording when he and Iron Man were
stranded on the Guardians of the Galaxy ship the
Benetar which Morty calls him out on like that's a
theme during the episode characters calling each
other out on their bits when they make the evil
Morty joke about him quitting Twitter and Morty
says but no one never quits Twitter yes it's meant
to be a joke about people in real life who always
say they're going to quit social media but then
never actually do but it's also a way that the
writers are saying that evil Morty will eventually
come back like he's not really gone he's just gone
for now the whole idea going forward is that Prime
rig is meant to be like the new big bad so evil
Morty's still around but they're kind of moving
past him on a narrative level Rick asked Morty
to kill him with a robitussin-based method of
some kind they have another meta bit about jokes
like bits about bits when space Beth shows up to
save them and then it just goes on and on and on
which they do again when they're disappearing into
their original realities like the [__] goes on
and on and on then during the new intro scene we
have to try and guess which of these are going
to wind up being scenes in actual episodes this
season the first one is Rick and Jerry skydiving
away from a giant flying squirrel which are real
animals but they're just regular size this
one just happens to be giant the next one is
Rick and Morty as Sherlock Holmes in Watson
in Victorian London talking to a version of
Jack the Ripper seemingly after he's just killed
someone like he has the bloody knife and the other
joke here too is that they don't seem bothered
by it at all there's a scene with a rake parade
with a giant Rick balloon space Beth the other
Beth Morty in summer then there's a scene of
Jerry wearing an armor suit in a very star Trekkie
looking assembly chamber with a bunch of different
races in the middle of a fight I'm not sure which
TV show or movie this armor suit is a reference
to but if you think it looks familiar just write
it below in the comments then there's a butter
Morty being dumped into a frying pan being used to
cook someone's breakfast and I believe that that's
like the fewest number of scenes in the intro
scene that we've seen before usually it seems
like there are more fake and real scenes when they
make it back we meet digestabot for the first time
the joke here is that Rick has modified the house
so much that there are basically any item that you
could possibly conceive of hidden inside the house
somewhere in fact in the trailer there was footage
from one of the later episodes where a bunch of
household items turn into Transformers and attack
them they said it the whole bit with them being
sent back to their original realities the reason
obviously why summer and Beth don't glow green is
because they're in their original reality and they
pay off the long-running bit from season two with
a Jerry Berry saying that they really did grab
the wrong Jerry and they've been with the wrong
Jerry this whole time ever since in fact at the
end of the episode there are like several season
two references with Rick breaking the fourth
wall referencing the fact that he is a fictional
character inside a TV show referencing the events
of season two literally like saying season two the
whole joke with the booger file naming convention
is a joke that they did during Morty's mind
blowers like a bunch of his files are named with
the booger naming convention summer reveals to bet
the secret about how every time Rick and Morty go
to a new reality they bury the old Rick and Morty
in the backyard setting up the bid at the end of
the episode where they bury the entire family plus
space Beth summer also reveals that Rick has set
up a vending machine to reward her for helping
him with what mostly look like Marvel characters
powers like there's X-Men there's some Avengers
here the gloves are obviously x23 Wolverine claws
it's x23 because there are only two claws in her
hands not three there's a cyclops visor there's a
Magneto looking helmet there's Thor's hammer I'm
not sure what the purple cubes are supposed to
be let me know in the comments if you think you do
most of these are supposed to be Marvel characters
when space Beth jokes about seeing them again
in about two years that's just a joke about her
Cameo scenes like I guess I'll have a cameo scene
in another two seasons but they turn it into like
a full episode crossover and at the end of the
episode when she says would it be okay if I came
around more often I think that's just the writer
saying we're gonna have her on the show more often
more Cameo scenes for her this season then there's
a whole lot going on on Rick's Original House in
his original reality which we've seen in multiple
episodes before through his memories but if you
didn't notice his house here his original one is
literally a copy of Walt's house from Breaking Bad
he trapped the entire world here in a Time Loop
when he took off years ago to start his quest to
find prime rig which they pay off with a joke
about his neighbor who's able to remember just
enough of each time Loop that he writes himself
knows revealing what's going on then Rick taking
pity on all them allowing them to die by breaking
the loop they explained the joke about him
creating the AI version of his wife just to hurt
himself just to remind him about his dead wife
and his dead daughter I explained how he basically
used the same voice print to create the garage AI
so he's kind of doing the same thing in the new
reality that they're living in he also reveals
that summer has basically the same personality
that his wife Diane did the combination 2 is safe
here 69247 probably is a reference to something
usually numbers like this wind up being references
but there weren't any special dates that I could
find so if you think you know what this is a
reference to just write it below in the comments
then we get a bunch of answers about what happened
to Morty's original family in the Cronenberg
reality only Jerry has survived his Beth and
summer died and Prime Rick is his real grandfather
but like I said he abandoned them 20 plus years
ago so Morty has never known prime rig the only
Rick he's ever known has been c-137 rig who was
just squatting there waiting for Prime break to
come back but over time the idea like they kind
of joke about this at the end of the episode too
about how c-137 rig really did grow to care about
them which is why Prime brick is so dangerous
because he doesn't care about anyone or anything
so like in all the episodes where they have
flashbacks and they show Rick holding baby Morty
those were pictures of c-137 Rick watching Morty
be born also because they're doing so many season
one callbacks I feel like Morty being distracted
by all the dirty magazines feels like a very big
deep cut to season one back on the Citadel the
scavenger aliens kind of look like they're dressed
as Jawas space Beth reveals that her mechanical
fingers are detachable weapons remember she's
kind of like another version of Rick like a very
Rick version of Beth and Rick replaces all of his
body parts on the regular Rick winds up making the
new upgraded version of his spaceship capable of
making the journey across realities the spaceship
might be in future episodes so I don't know how
long they're going to keep this around but like
in the trailer you see Morty accidentally blow
it up so it might not be around for the entire
season when he travels through the rift in space
time it's meant to be a big 2001 Space Odyssey
reference when he's traveling through the vortex
with the lights shining on his eyes Cronenberg
Jerry makes a bunch of Pop Culture references he
even says Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns helps
him come to terms with their reality move on with
his new reality the joke there is that there's
also a bunch of mutants that older Batman fights
in that story and in the Cronenberg reality
pretty much everybody has been mutated into
a version of themselves and obviously the other
joke here that Jerry left on his own without the
rest of the family becomes the perfect version
of himself so the joke there is that without
everyone else Jerry is actually a pretty decent
person there's another super deep cut reference
with a downbeat game on the package it reads two
to three minutes of fun that's just a meta joke
about how long they're bit about the game can go
on while it's still funny like oh we can get about
two to three minutes out of this joke when Jerry
references The Four Agreements that's actually a
real life self-help book but also quoting Batman
in The Dark Knight Returns a bunch more they've
referenced Jerry's unemployment it again which is
a big deep cut for the early season saying that
they'll find him another job in another reality
then like I said they confirmed the space Beth
really is the true Beth the regular Beth has been
the Clone this whole time c-137 Rick explains the
rest of his backstory with prime Rick he makes
a Minecraft reference and when Morty makes a
k-hole reference that's just a joke about being on
a drug trip they have this whole bit with the fake
out and the naked rig they reveal later that that
really was the Prime rake this whole time and then
in keeping with the theme of the episode moving on
in general Rick has to choose to move on instead
of pursuing Prime rig although obviously this
isn't the end of it it's sort of like the new evil
Morty of the show like the new overarching villain
when he's trying to get Rick to leave Morty also
references the pilot episode rant Rick and Morty
for a hundred years Rick and Morty forever and
forever 100 years Rick and Morty thanks the
showrunner in real life said that they could
theoretically go for a hundred Seasons although
they've only been confirmed for 10 like that big
70 episode order only takes them to 10 seasons we
find out that Rick's secretly child proves Morty
and things around him while he is sleeping and
they remind him to child-proof Jerry setting up
the whole twist with the old season 2 version of
Jerry that they misplaced when they got the wrong
one at the Jerry Berry when they find their
real version of Jerry in the other reality he
accidentally went to a couple years ago the scene
in the dining room is meant to be reminiscent of a
scene from season 2 which Rick calls out breaking
the fourth wall again then when they get back to
their reality they call the wrong Jerry that they
picked up so many years ago season two Jerry but
also setting up the bit with Mr frontals making
them have to switch or move to another reality
again Beth asks at the end of the episode how
many times have you done this when they are
burying the family again is that this time there's
space Beth look he found another reality with his
exact makeup of the group so by the end of this
episode Morty has done it at least four times
Rick now because he moved to the Cronenberg
reality first before season one has done at
least five times but obviously is a big call back
to the joke where Rick said in season three we can
only do this a couple more times Morty but in
reality if Morty's done it up to four times in
six seasons now they do it almost every single
season with just a couple breaks between the
I'm denial Rick is also meant to be a call back to
the events of pickle Rick when he went to therapy
like I said space Beth says she's going to come
around more that just means more Cameo scenes
more crossovers for her in the future and in the
post-credits scene they revealed that Prime Rick
really was the naked one messing with c-137 Rick
Jerry makes a Mortal Kombat fatality reference but
they also reveal Prime Rick can't be killed by
a lot of conventional means like he's modified
his body so that he heals almost instantly from
most wounds killing Cronenberg Jerry proving
c-137 Rick correct that he really doesn't care
about anyone or anything like Cronenberg Jerry
Was His original Jerry but when he says he never
got close to the concept of a Jerry that's because
he basically abandoned Beth when she was younger
so he wasn't around for her getting married to
Jerry so Prime Rick never met Jerry but I'm sure
there's going to be a ton of questions about the
new stuff that they set up during this but the
big idea obviously Prime rake is going to be the
new overarching villain eventually he and c-137
Rick will go against each other in the same way
that Rick and Morty fought evil Morty but there
was a big twist on that like it wasn't quite the
fight that you expected and evil Morty threw
us all for a loop and he's like you know what
I really just want to escape I'm just trying to
get out of here this whole time so post all your
theories in the comments below what is like the
final confrontation with prime Rick in c-137 Rick
going to be like if you spotted any other Easter
eggs and references or callbacks to previous
seasons in the episode that I didn't mention in
the video just write them Below in the comments
in my full episode 2 video we'll post next week
after they release it I'll put a link for all my
Rick and Morty episode videos in the description
below you can click here for my Full House of the
Dragon episode 4 trailer video and click here for
my Full House of the Dragon episode 3 video thank
you so much for watching everyone stay stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!